,
entrevue de Louis-Philippe
Ouimet avec Denis Villeneuve
Denis Villeneuve a refusé que
son film soit diffusé sur une
plateforme en ligne. Pour lui,
c'était le grand écran
- Denis Villeneuve, après
quatre ans de travail, un an
de pandémie, "Dune" sort enfin
en grande première mondiale
à la Mostra de Venise.
Anxieux, enthousiaste,
tout ça à la fois?
DENIS VILLENEUVE,
réalisateur du film "Dune"
- Je dirais... je vais être
soulagé quand je vais être
assis dans la salle parce que
les choses, au moment où
on se parle, les choses
progressent tellement rapidement
puis il y a tellement de
changements au quotidien
que, moi, je vais y croire
quand je vais être assis là-bas.
Ouais, ça fait que... c'est ça,
c'est, je dirais, un exercice de
lâcher-prise. Ça va être sorti
dans un contexte imparfait.
Puis, t'sais, j'accepte le fait
que c'est la sécurité des gens
avant tout, là, ça fait qu'on va
voir, selon les territoires
comment ça se passe.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Je suis un grand fan de
"Dune" que j'ai lu je ne sais
pas combien de fois. C'est
un livre à la fois complexe,
hein? C'est les Harkonnen qui se
battent contre les Atréides
pour la production de l'épée
gériatrique qui permet d'avoir
des visions, de voyager dans la
galaxie. Tu parles de religion,
de politique, d'écologie
et j'ai un peu l'impression
que dans Paul Atréides
se retrouve beaucoup
de Denis Villeneuve, que ça a
vraiment influencé
votre parcours. De quelle façon?
- C'est ça, c'est un livre
que j'ai dû lire au début
de l'adolescence, vers 13 ou
14 ans où j'ai... ce qu'on suit,
c'est l'histoire d'un jeune
homme qui défie, qui se cherche,
qui définit son identité et qui
a de la difficulté à négocier
avec un héritage génétique,
familial, politique, un contexte
environnemental aussi.
C'est quelqu'un qui a beaucoup
de poids sur ses épaules et qui,
au fil de cette histoire
où il va se retrouver à perdre
beaucoup, va tranquillement
se retrouver et va se retrouver,
va trouver son identité en étant
en contact avec un peuple
qui va l'accueillir, un peuple
du désert. Et c'est comme...
cette idée que quelqu'un puisse
enfin définir son identité
au contact d'une autre culture.
Moi, ça m'avait beaucoup
touché à l'époque.
♪ ♪ ♪
- La pandémie a durement
touché la sortie de "Dune"
et en décembre 2020, vous avez
critiqué la décision de
Warner de sortir aux États-Unis
simultanément le film sur HBO
Max. Est-ce que votre pensée
a évolué sur ce sujet-là ou
vous maintenez votre position?
- Non, je maintiens ma position,
c'est-à-dire que l'idée que dans
la crise, il y ait une décision
unilatérale qui a été faite de
sortir toute une série de films
simultanément sur le grand écran
et dans un service de streaming.
Et ça, c'est le problème. Il y a
plusieurs problèmes avec ça,
mais le premier problème,
c'est de ne pas avoir consulté
personne puis que ça ait été
fait... C'est un coup de
poignard dans le dos pour moi.
Puis, c'est quelque chose que
moi... Le cinéma,
c'est un travail d'équipe.
Mais je continue à penser que
c'est une idée ridicule de
sortir... c'est un geste juste
pour mousser la... les actions
de HBO Max, et ça n'a aucun
rapport avec... C'est même
un geste qui est dangereux pour
les films puis pour le futur
des films. Puis, je ne crois pas
du tout à ce modèle-là.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Pendant mes vacances,
j'ai revu tous vos films
et puis là, je me suis posé
la question suivante, parce que
vous êtes né à Bécancour, vous
avez fait vos études secondaires
et collégiales à Trois-Rivières,
vous êtes diplômé en cinéma de
l'UQAM. Comment est-ce possible
d'arriver aussi haut
à Hollywood?
- Il faut dire, j'ai un peu
d'obsessions, je veux dire...
J'étais avec des gens...
Moi, je fais juste du cinéma!
(rires)
J'en mange! C'est ce que je
fais. C'est ma vie. Le cinéma,
c'est ce qui m'a permis d'être
en relation avec les autres,
justement, c'est ce qui m'a
permis d'être en relation avec
la vie, d'être en relation avec
le monde. C'est une obsession.
Mes enfants se moquent de moi
parce que je.... tous les temps
libres y sont consacrés.
C'est mon hobby,
c'est ma passion, c'est ma joie,
le cinéma, c'est...
Donc, il y a peut-être un côté
compulsif, obsessif qui fait que
ça m'a poussé là. Le reste,
c'est beaucoup de chance aussi.
J'ai été chanceux dans tout
mon parcours. Il y a eu beaucoup
de moments-clés. J'ai eu
un flair pour m'associer
aux bonnes personnes. Ça, je
dirais ça, je dirais que j'ai,
dans mon parcours, j'ai eu
comme... je me suis associé
à des gens qui m'ont pas brimé.
Un des premiers conseils que
j'ai reçus avant de commencer
à travailler à Hollywood,
ça a été Martin Scorcese qui m'a
dit : "Le plus important,
c'est de demeurer intact...
dans le processus."
Puis, j'ai eu cette chance-là,
de demeurer intact, je veux
dire, d'être entouré de gens
qui me protègent et pas de gens
qui essaient de me contrôler
ou qui essaient de me... ouais.
♪ ♪ ♪
- "Dune" peut ouvrir la porte
à une série télé, à d'autres
films. C'est un univers qui est
assez vaste, merci. Sur quoi
vous travaillez présentement?
Sur d'autres gros projets,
sur...?
- Hum... J'essaie de ne pas trop
éparpiller. Je suis quelqu'un
qui est assez monomaniaque.
J'essaie de travailler
sur un projet à la fois. Donc,
évidemment, la deuxième partie
de "Dune" va être une priorité.
Puis il y a... je suis en train
de commencer à travailler sur
un film sur la vie de Cléopâtre
aussi qui est un projet
qui m'habite depuis longtemps,
encore là qui était un projet
que j'aurais pas osé faire il y
a 10 ans, mais maintenant, j'ai,
je dirais, les connaissances
techniques pour pouvoir faire
le film dont je rêve. Puis c'est
ça, je dirais que ce sont les
projets, les projets proéminents
en place en ce moment.
- Denis Villeneuve, je vous
souhaite tout le meilleur
pour "Dune".
- Merci.
- Pour qu'il y ait une suite
bientôt. Merci!
- Grand merci.
♪